[Applause]
federation
[Music]
[Applause]
the overly emotional long term
she may be emotional but she's not
talking about it
oh she's showing you the 10 chain read
it and weave that's what she did oh
she's got something to say
i will make this long but
since you won't answer my calls i have
no choice too long didn't read hey
her first opponent it's the text that's
guaranteed to piss you off give it up
okay
[Applause]
hey
you better have a fourth game
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
but supremely agonizing
because your friend is
that's
[Applause]
she's gonna keep us right like an uber
on new year's eve unbelievable she
didn't have [ __ ] to say now rounding out
k's team
give it up for the one that dings and it
rings in the dark
[Applause]
peaches and eggplants for everybody
he's giving
are classic out ain't move it's the
produce for me
you're a first now i want a fair
conversation tonight so turn on your
read receipts and reply in a timely
fashion now pop thumbs up let's do this
i know that you're probably asleep but i
can't stop thinking about that thing
that you said to me five years ago at
sizzler
[Applause]
oh man she's gonna screenshot this and
she's gonna send it to her friends and
analyze it with our friends for a week
to come oh
look at this we have a versailles 2 a.m
wid and three dots both require more
patience than a black kid waiting to get
picked up from school
what you doing your parents are not
coming they forgot about
oh 2 you
id is down now his strategy usually
requires him to send multiple texts and
wait for a response that's not going to
work here he can't bugaboo your way out
of this one
[Music]
you don't have to step out of the fish
you are embarrassing yourself 2 am i've
never had this problem get up
with a classic dig
[Applause]
you're there just say something
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[ __ ] are you gonna do with that
oh great android couldn't handle a
thumbs up android can't see those kind
of reacts she was totally defenseless
and divisive
communications
[Applause]
you